Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This will be my Game of Thrones
A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms
trailer video for the new series
they just announced.
HBO just officially ordered
a Night of the Seven Kingdoms.
to series is like
the next big Game of Thrones prequel.
They're doing all explain what's going
on, where it fits in the timeline
and what their plan is for how they're
going to adapt the book material
for this story. George R.R.
Martin was talking a lot about this.
He is heavily involved
in writing the episodes right now,
so it's not like they're just making up
a whole bunch of stuff on their own.
It's kind of the same way that they built
House of the Dragon with George R.R.
Martin, helping them build out the stories
because the original book
material
for that stories is relatively scarce.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Of course, I'll do episode videos
for when it premieres.
I'll explain
what the timeline is for that too.
But if you haven't read the books,
A Night of the Seven Kingdoms is the name
for the collected series of novellas
about the adventures of Sir Duncan
the Tall and Aegon the fifth Targaryen,
affectionately known
as the Tales of Dunk and Egg.
But George R.R.
Martin already said,
We're not going to call the show
Tales of Dunk and Egg
because that would make
it sound like a sitcom,
which does sound kind of funny, like HBO
doing a Game of Thrones sitcom series.
Do I say something?
Is it mean?
What do I say? What?
Oh, we've got to. They're ready.
Oh, sorry.
One of the major differences, though,
just in the way
the show would feel, the way it would work
from, say, House of the Dragon right now
or the main show, Game of Thrones,
is that it mostly just follows Sir Duncan
the tall an aegon the fifth
when he was a boy serving
as Duncan's squire about 90 years
before the events of the main show.
So whereas House of the Dragon
in the original Game of Thrones series
follow this massive cast of characters
and there's not like one single main
character like Jon Snow, Diners
are arguably the two biggest characters,
but that was really only right at the end.
And you could argue for most of the shows,
all the characters
were an ensemble together
during a Night of the Seven Kingdoms.
Dunk and Egg are the de facto
main characters now.
There are a lot of other really important
characters to the story,
but it mostly follows those two.
It picks up
just after the first Blackfire rebellion.
So we're about 80 years
after the Dance of the Dragons,
which they're
starting on House of the Dragon right now.
So it's a couple of generations
after the characters
we're watching on House of the Dragon
right now.
Pretty much
all those characters would be dead
by this time, including those Dragons.
Because one of the other really notable
things about this period in history
is that it picks up about 50 or 60 years
after the death of the last Dragon
that belonged to the Targaryen family,
while they still sat on the Iron throne.
We know dangerous dragons were eventually
hatched from some stolen dragon eggs
taken from dream fire many, many years
earlier when Dream Fire was still alive.
We actually saw her in the Dragon Pit
during House of the Dragon Season one,
when Aymond tried to prove himself
by actually claiming a dragon
from the pit itself.
Later, Dream Fire winds up being ridden
by Helena, who has Dragon dream.
So Dream fire Dragon dreams.
You get the association there.
But for about 150 years
there were no dragons alive.
There were dragon eggs because we know
about dinosaurs, dragon eggs.
But none of them had hatched
the major conflicts during the night
of the Seven Kingdoms in the realm
just during this period in history
are the second Blackfire rebellion.
The Bloodraven is very active
before he became the Three-Eyed Raven.
He's also one of the Targaryen bastards
who's related to Maester
Amon, who is also very active
at this point in history.
Maester Aemon was actually the older brother
of Aegon the Fifth the egg in the title.
Dunk and Egg.
He actually mentions egg when he lay dying
during the Game of Thrones series. Hey,
I dream
first.
I was told
the funny thing about Maister
and he actually told us to Jon Snow
during the early seasons
of Game of Thrones
when Jon Snow was getting worked up
about what was happening with the war,
the Five Kings Maester Aemon had to set him
straight, like, Look, kid,
I've been through this before.
I had to watch all my family die,
meet horrible ends.
But because they had taken the black base,
Draymond was trying to tell him, No,
you can't rush to help out.
You took the black.
You took an oath, Mr.
Aemon was supposed to ascend
to the Iron throne.
Remember? He's Aegon,
the fierce older brother.
So he was ahead of him
in the line of succession.
Their oldest brother had died from the pox
in their second oldest
brother was Aryan Targaryen,
the one who infamously died after
drinking a cup of wildfire, claiming
that it would transform him into a dragon.
So when Aemon was going to officially
be recognized as the heir apparent,
he formally took the black
becoming a Maester to the night's watch
because he didn't want another situation
like the Dance of the Dragons
to come around again,
where it turned into
a battle of succession within the family.
Again, like he didn't
want to have to fight his brother
for the iron throne again.
And that's how egg from Tales of Dunk and
egg became aegon the Fifth.
But that didn't happen until many,
many years later in his lifetime.
Pretty much everything
that they would cover
in a night of the Seven Kingdoms series,
even through like four or five seasons,
would be when he's a young boy.
But the idea is that
there are still a lot of conflicts,
a lot of really big things
and really important
figures in the realm during this period,
even though
it seems like a relatively chill period
within the target and family.
We had the later Blackfire rebellions,
a very young Maester Aemon
like the Chad version of Maester Aemon,
the Chad version of The Bloodraven
and the Boy Aegon,
who would eventually become Aegon
the fifth ascending to the Iron Throne
when he was much older.
If they do wind up
doing the first Blackfire rebellion,
they might do that as its own show.
Just because so much happens
during that period,
you could turn that into like four
or five seasons of its own show,
but it feels almost
just like what they're doing right now
with the Dance of the Dragons, which is
probably why they're skipping past it.
Maybe they'll circle back around
or do it in some flashbacks.
During the upcoming night of the Seven
Kingdoms series.
Like they'll probably refer to it
because it's relatively recent.
After the first Blackfire rebellion,
when the series picks up,
assuming there aren't a bunch of big time
jumps during a night of the Seven
Kingdoms, the first Blackfire
rebellion was about 15 years before season
one would begin that Blackfire
rebellion started because King Aegon
the fourth sired a ton of bastards
like more bastards than Robert Baratta
and did, legitimized
a bunch of them in his favorite one,
the most powerful
one named Damon took the name Blackfire
after he'd been legitimized
the same name as Aegon, the Conqueror's
Valyrian Blade, which had been passed down
since Aegon
the Conqueror. From King to King.
It was intended to be a sign of right
to rule,
like each king would eventually pass it
to the heir apparent.
Eventually, Aegon, the fourth gave
the valerian sword Blackfire
to his bastard Damian,
instead of his legitimate heir, Darren.
The second they wound up fighting
a bitter war over the iron throne,
that was the first Blackfire rebellion
that eventually the second
Blackfire rebellion, which does happen
during a night of the Seven Kingdoms.
Like we'd actually see a version
that play out
during a night of the Seven Kingdoms.
That was Damon
and some of the other Blackfire
children who had come back from Essos
after they'd formed the Golden Company.
That's basically what happens
with a lot of bastards from Westeros
is the Golden Company
is made up of a lot of Highborn bastards
from Westeros or people who are exiled.
So during the second Blackfire
rebellion, it's a lot of the same energy,
but it just Demon's Children
and people from the Golden Company.
George R.R.
Martin just did a big blog post explaining
what's going on with their plan
is for adapting the books
and how many episodes are going to do
per season,
how many seasons they have planned.
He said that each season
would be about six episodes.
There's a bit of a shorter episode count,
but there's less book
material to adapt in.
Right now they have at least three Seasons
Plan, which would adapt
each of the three Dunk and Egg novellas
that he has already written.
He did say he planned on writing
more Dunk and Egg story,
so it does sound like they want to go
for like four, maybe even five seasons,
but the episode count
would stay a little bit shorter.
The first season would adapt.
The first novella,
which is called Hedge Night.
He did say that the title of the show
would probably change.
Like right now, HBO has the longest title
in the history of show titles ever,
and they're just using it
as a working title.
So they might just call the show
The Hedge Night.
But that's the story of how Aegon became
Ser Duncan
the tall Squire in house, or Duncan
The Tall became a knight.
There's a whole bunch of drama
they get up to in this story.
Like it all goes down at this
famous tourney
called the Tourney at Ashford,
where a bunch of people wind up dying.
There's a lot of chaos
in the line of succession.
A whole bunch of shit just goes down.
They also do something really cool that
they haven't done on any of the shows yet.
They actually have a trial by seven, like
the Seven Gods of the Faith of the Seven.
We've seen Trial by Combat Before,
which is two parties either
fighting each other over an actual trial
that they're having,
like someone is accusing someone else
of something with the defendant
having a chance to win their freedom,
if he can kill the accuser
or force them to submit
or they both choose champions
like Tyrion in Searcy,
each choosing Oberyn Martell
in the mountain to fight in their stead.
But trial by combat is just a
one on one thing.
Trial
by Seven is a full on seven on seven.
So you have 14 people on
the field of battle just fighting it out.
The terms of victory are the same, though.
The winner is the last man standing.
One of the other
interesting things about Ser Duncan
the Tall is that he's also the ancestor
of Brienne of Tarth.
And his story, especially initially in
his life, is very similar to Brian's
in that her only wish in her entire
life is just to become a knight,
and she eventually becomes the Lord
Commander of the Kingsguard to Bran.
Basically the same thing happens with Ser
Duncan the Tall, where he never knew
his parents.
He was raised in flea
bottom, is an orphan,
and during that period
it was almost impossible
to become a knight
if you weren't of noble birth.
Eventually, he's able to start out
as a squire to a hedge knight.
Thus the title of the Sir book named Sir
Arlen Penny Tree, who teaches him
sword fighting,
How to take care of Horses.
All the basic skills
you need to be a knight.
Then the story takes a Very Knight's
Tale kind of turn.
If you remember that movie, A Knight's
Tale with Heath
Ledger, the story of ser Duncan
the Tall plays out
a little bit
like Heath Ledger's story in that movie.
We're on the way to The Tourney at
Ashford This very famous tourney
where all this drama goes down.
Sir Arlen winds up dying in Ser Duncan.
The tall wears his armor,
trying to compete in his stead.
When he gets closer,
he winds up running into a bald
boy at an inn
who he allows to become his squire.
And at the time he just calls himself egg.
But he eventually learns that that is egg
on the fifth, like the heir
to the iron throne.
Eventually,
when he becomes a squire, though,
like when they actually become a pair,
he isn't the official heir.
Like there's still other brothers
that are older than him
in the line of succession.
Without getting into big spoilers
or anything like that, a bunch of drama
goes down at The Turning.
Ashford This trial by seven happens
in Aegon's father maekar officially allows
Ser Duncan the tall,
to become part of the royal family
and become the official knight
to aegon the fifth.
They go on a bunch of adventures together,
he eventually ascends the Iron throne,
and once he did, Dunk became his Lord
Commander of the Kingsguard,
like Brienne
did later in the timeline to Bran.
So the core of the series is all
about the friendship of dunk and egg.
That's why most people who read the books
think of the story
as the tales of Dunk and Egg.
Right now, it sounds like HBO's plan
is either to release this
during the final season
of House of the Dragon or like the year
right after House of the Dragon ends.
So there is no yearlong break.
We don't wait three or four years
before the next Game of Thrones
spin off or sequel series.
George R.R.
Martin also said
all the other sequels, prequels,
all those other spin off
shows are still in contention.
They're still working on them.
So we'll probably hear about more than
being greenlighted in future years, too.
He did make a big deal about clarifying
that nothing has actually been canceled,
like none of the sequels or prequels
that you've heard about
have actually been canceled.
They're all still being developed,
which includes the Jon Snow sequel series.
I just did a really big video about that.
You can click here for the teaser
for that and click Here for My House
The Dragon Season two teaser Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.